a quick show of hands how many of you
remember playing with these as kids
awesome I for one can close my eyes and
reminisce the absolute sense of
imagination and creativity that these
blocks could evoke now imagine if you
could use these blocks to create a world
of your own a real world so that could
be something like you being sent back in
time to 16-24 to recreate the city of
New York how cool would that be can you
imagine the endless possibilities well
that's exactly the feeling that I got
when I looked at my job description
about six years back the project in this
instance was the first of its kind city
within a city concept in the world and
it was called the dubai international
financial centre so as it happened the
government of dubai had latched onto
this opportunity that there was no
financial center which was serving the
region between london and singapore now
I probably know what some of you are
thinking here you're probably thinking
well we know this region has a lot of
potential but then we also know that
this region is synonymous with certain
other words red tape corruption poor
infrastructure social and political
turmoil and you would be absolutely
correct however we are not today here to
talk about the present we are here to
talk about a future a future in which
you all could be global leaders so how
about we take a look at the macro
economic future for this part of the
world if we were having this
conversation around and say 2009 this
region's overall economic output would
have been something around forty percent
of the size of the US economy fast
forward on to 2020 this number could be
as high as fifty five percent and and by
2030 this number could be seventy
percent or even higher in a sense this
region would be imperative for your
business no matter what business you're
in and the cool part is that the trends
which are changing these numbers are
already underway about a decade back if
you were running an international
business your business would have been a
part of what was known as the east-west
trading corridor and the east-west
trading corridor used to contribute to
about eight point five dollars out of
every ten dollars exchanging hands
globally however in the last decade
there is another Force which is changing
the landscape of global trade completely
and this phenomena ladies and gentlemen
is known as a New Silk Route let's try
to understand this phenomenon through
the eyes of our first protagonist
Shanley now Shanley is a
first-generation Chinese entrepreneur
she started a small medical disposable
medical supplies business back in 2003
she was catering clients to
predominantly in Europe and in the
Americas however as we all know by 2009
things have changed the world was
different poor economic conditions and
the fact that regulations had become
really stringent in the West forced her
to consider other markets it was at that
point in time that she heard about this
whole story of growth in Africa and
India and the Middle East not
surprisingly 16 months later Shanley was
on a plane halfway across the globe and
she started a very small reacts port hub
in Dubai with just five employees in
2010 I was fortunate enough to meet
Shanley again and this time around boy
had the fortunes changed her five-man
operation had grown to over 100
employees and a business had grown
twelve hundred percent and let me assure
you Shalee is not an exception in fact
according to the World Bank this zone or
the south-south trading corridor
or the New Silk Route is going to
contribute to seven dollars out of every
ten dollars exchanging hands globally by
2030 I saw the proof of this growth
firsthand myself from the city that I
was privileged to start when we started
in 2004 these were the clients which
were registered with us 20 of them and
these are all of them I would love you
to guess as to how many clients that
this city hosted a 1400 plus and this is
just a small sample of the kind of
clients it hosts but then the business
and economics is just one part of the
equation there is a far greater social
force which is completely transforming
this part of the world now let me ask
you all a question at this point in time
if I asked all of you which country or
region in the world today produces the
highest proportion of women
entrepreneurs what will you answer be I
bet a lot of you would be saying Silicon
Valley but would you be surprised if I
said no it is not Silicon Valley but in
fact it's in places like Yemen and
Uganda we have forty percent of the
entrepreneurs of women let's try to
understand this phenomena to the eyes of
our second pet organist naja naja lies a
mother of four and she's a Saudi
national ever since she was 16 she
always wanted to start her own private
brand of code clothing label
unfortunately the society did not give
her much of a chance in fact apart from
a supportive husband nobody really came
to help and added to that the
regulations in Saudi Arabia for women
entrepreneurs was so stringent that she
was not even allowed to represent
herself in front of the government and
in spite of all these limitations nashla
finally broke through the glass ceiling
and started her own private label in
2012 and named it Sheila
now having seen modular and by the way
naturalizer one to your left now having
seen modular and having kind of heard a
story do you believe you really
understand the needs and aspirations of
Nigel as a customer and this is where
most multinationals make a mistake they
pick up a product or service from one
part of the world and take it to another
part without really understanding the
ground realities till you really
understand the trials and tribulations
of nodular do you really understand the
environment that she operates in it
won't really justify that Nigella gives
a business to you
so now going back to our example of the
Lego bricks this region is like a pack
of Lego bricks where all the pieces are
coming together some of these pieces are
broken some are not there and there are
others which are still under formation
and it would be your responsibility as
future leaders to put all these pieces
together and while you do that you need
to remember that there is no precedence
so you need to push the state of school
you need to be innovative but at the
same time you need to be patient and you
need to be respectful and there are a
couple of principles which I personally
like to follow which I would love to
share with you all first read but don't
always take the mass media too seriously
secondly learn but start by unlearning
and finally every opportunity that you
get go out and meet the nudge laws and
the Shanley's of the world try to soak
in a little bit of their culture and
their life and I must admit I made my
own fair share of mistakes and my first
stint in the Middle East I was supposed
to start a woman's only banking product
for one of the multinational clients and
I went into the market imagining them to
be my customers and I was not totally of
the mark they were in fact a part of the
segment that I was going to create it to
but I made one fundamental mistake I
forgot the other end of the spectrum so
let me try to end this presentation with
one of my favorite quotes that the mind
is like a parachute it does not work if
it doesn't open thank you
you
you